good evening ladies and gentlemen
the nominees for the best performance by
an actress are
isabella johnny in the story of adele h
and margaret in tummy
louise fletcher in one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
glenda jackson in header
carol kane in hester street
and the winner is
the winner is louise fletcher
well it looks like you all hated me so
much
that you've given me this award for it
and i'm loving every minute of it
and all i can say is i've
i've loved being hated by you
i'd like to thank fred roos for
remembering me
milos forman for choosing me
michael douglas and saul's ants for
taking a chance and giving me a chance
and jack nicholson
and a cast of actors
whose professionalism
humor
and capacity for getting into their
roles made being in a mental institution
like being in a mental institution
and if you'll excuse me
for my mother
and my father
i want to say thank you for teaching me
to have
a dream
you are seeing
my dream
come true
thank you
you